but then i'm a kid and i have a gun next
to my [ __ ] dick yeah you know what if
i shot your dick off saying [ __ ] like
this and he's laughing but he's laughing
but he's also kind of serious yeah and i
remember just
freaked the [ __ ] out right and then he's
like look at this [ __ ] he's [ __ ] you
know he's scared he's like go [ __ ]
shoot you but he would yeah he would
have shot me yeah and i remember i went
home and i [ __ ] cried dude
oh man i went home that night and just
out of nowhere i started [ __ ] crying
because i was like i could have died
right and i was like dude in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast i hope you guys are staying
blessed you're uh happy out there may
the lord be with you i hope the lord has
given you many blessings a season so you
know whether you celebrate it or not i
hope you guys have good company a good
time good health uh just a good position
in life man you know you know i was
talking about this with mariel on the
the previous podcast but i think
holidays now when i go back home starts
to make me feel
it doesn't have like the same feeling
number one because you know new
different family members have started
different lives we don't really gather
like we used to but other thing is that
every year i get to see how old my
parents are getting you know so it's
like yeah there's there you know for you
there is that kind of disconnect in
terms of like location you have that
barrier between you guys and so you
don't get that face time with your
parents as regularly is somebody like me
where my parents you know they don't
live exactly close but they're driving
distance they're about 30 minutes from
where i am yeah no 30 miles i'm sorry so
maybe roughly about 40 minutes 50
minutes
um and like
when i get that feeling of over the
years of like damn you guys are getting
old i can only imagine when you see them
that every once in a while that you do
yeah what that must feel like it's weird
like uh i'll um and it's not when i just
look at them and i'm talking to them
they feel and look the same yeah it's
when i take a picture uh i'll take a
photo and i look at my face next to this
you know what you're right you're right
i do have those moments too when we take
like family photos like let's say we get
together for dinner and we take that
picture i look at it i'm like
wow yeah they got old wow but then we
got old yeah
yeah a hundred percent yeah and i think
that it's it's so weird man every time i
look at it like i was i had like a clip
of my mom where i was just recording her
on the couch watching tv
and i had this weird little uh deja vu
thing because
it just reminded me when i was a kid i
used to watch
my mom would be next to me watching tv
yeah but the person in front of me now
is just a lot older yeah i'm like oh
[ __ ] man there's a there's gonna be a
finite time where i get to see this
picture again yeah and it's just it's
gonna disappear dude you know what hit
home with me years back i saw there was
this graphic designer who's super into
creating like infographics right
basically stats and creating graphic
design with it and um he
was thinking about because he lived in a
different country i believe from his
parents and so
he was talking about the average number
of times he gets to see its parents in a
year usually and based on life
expectancy rate he basically charted
that out right and so there's like
individual human um like silhouettes
there and he put in red the number of
frequency or like the frequency of rate
that he can actually see them and how
much time he has left yeah i looked at
that and i was like holy [ __ ] and it hit
him the same way too like holy [ __ ] i
gotta do whatever i can to try to spend
more time with them at least like call
them talk to them because
looking at this chart makes me realize
my time with them is so much limited
yeah and it goes into that perspective
of like
oh you know how important it is for what
we do with our time right yeah and you
know this might be repetitive from the
last podcast but i don't [ __ ] care
it's just i just really spent on my mind
yeah yeah i forgot what i saw but it had
to do with the idea that uh people tell
you that you have uh 24 hours within a
day but that's a lie because eight of
those hours is sleep right and then the
other um 10 hours or eight hours or so
is work so what do you do with that free
time yeah so it's like you've been told
this lie that you have 24 hours in a day
to do what you want yeah and it's not
necessarily no it's not it's you don't
have 24 hours yeah you actually have a
lot less than that a majority that time
is either you spent eating
or going to sleep or working right so
it's like what do you do at this time
and it kind of like puts in that
perspective of
really just
making everything count even if it's a
job that you're doing right like i i
find that to be a little
i wish i would have found that out a
little earlier
you know
like oh [ __ ] because i think i'm pretty
still i'm still relatively good with my
time i can always be doing a little more
yeah but it's weird when it's put into
that perspective he was like hey you
actually don't have 24 hours you have
about ten to eight mm-hmm
for sure oh [ __ ] and on top of that
you're a human being so even let's say
hypothetically you do have 10 hours
doesn't mean you're going to maximize
those 10 hours you're not learning a
language all those 10 hours you're not
traveling you know exactly and you know
there's going to be times when you're
tired where you're burned out but like
that's why i respect you know these
people who are able to just have that
discipline and consistency with their
work ethic yeah somebody like kobe for
example right that's why i looked up to
him in terms of his work ethic so much
because this guy not only did polyphasic
sleeping which is you break your sleeps
into naps right and i think he did two
uh
two naps during the day of three hours
each so he slept three hour blocks and
then every other hour would be well most
of it would be dedicated to training and
practicing and it's just like dude to do
that [ __ ] day in and day out for as long
as he played basketball just to keep
himself at the top it takes a crazy
person man it takes a crazy person to be
like all right i'm gonna ignore this
pain ignore this injury um the fact that
i got to spend more time with my kids
more time with my wife all of that all
those sacrifices came with the territory
of being great you know so when i look
at that it's it's something that i
aspire to and that inspires me man
but again it's not so easy to do that on
a daily basis you gotta die in a
helicopter now too man
come on man that's too soon still
still bro
[Laughter]
let me just tell you how much i respect
kobe i'm a sacramento kings fan and i
have him on my wall that's respect
that's respect guys if you guys know
about the rivalry between sacramento and
l.a like to have a [ __ ] kobe poster
on your wall that's respect i always
loved watching it play even when we
would go against kobe yeah it was just
so fun watching him play because he just
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was going
to do yeah you know so i remember just
getting pissed but being like damn that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] sick yeah you know his
work ethic is something that's very hard
to follow and i don't think everybody
can do it i'm for sure 99 people can't
really do it but if those for those
people out there in that one percent
that's searching for greatness he's a
great example of it yes you know um mike
tyson as well yeah bruce lee seriously
these two lesbians
[Laughter]
that one inspires me the most for some
reason this one is um
that's why this is one vote is a little
out of place
i'm waiting for tommy to create somebody
that's another one of my heroes
aesthetically it goes together it goes
aesthetically really yeah i love this
this art piece too by the way it's like
it's a representation of l.a right right
um but these people are people that i
admire a lot you know bruce lee mike
tyson and kobe bryant um one of the
things that i really enjoyed about kobe
was how he
you know while he was still around how
he decided to be after his after he
retired he left
he left no doors open right there's
he left himself as an undeniable force
when somebody talks about greatness and
what he does you have an idea of two
people kobe bryant and michael jordan in
the nba for sure even lebron james
people speak about him now nobody talks
about lebron james the way they talk
about kobe and jordan no right which
number one for for what kobe did to
follow up what jordan did for them to
have them in the same conversation yeah
is pretty [ __ ] insane you know when
you really think about it because jordan
was the epitome of what basketball is in
terms of being an elite absolutely but
now there's a conversation of elite oh
is it kobe or is it jordan yeah that's
so hard to do not to mention i think the
biggest thing here too is
kobe had jordan's respect yeah that's
not easy to come by you know what i mean
especially when somebody
is mimicking your style of play to the
point where it's like a mirror image of
you right and we learned um after kobe's
passing just how close mj and kobe were
right like uh mike spoke at kobe's
eulogy at the staples center and i don't
think a lot of the public knew just how
close they actually were right people
might not know i didn't either and i'm a
kobe fanatic i didn't know that but that
was the thing they kept that
relationship private and and i respect
that so much so for example too if you
guys haven't seen his uh his speech at
uh uh his at the eulogy yeah he talked
about how kobe would text him in like
the middle of night like 12 18
he's like talking about like how to like
further his daughter's career like in
basketball like what were you thinking
when you were 12. yeah is that first of
all two in the morning and that's 12. i
was trying to play baseball
that's his like winners mentality yeah
and there's not a lot of like nba
players that you see after retirement
where they still look as good as kobe
did yeah right yeah or
happy yeah and fulfilled and i think
that was the thing is that like he just
strived for greatness in whatever it is
that he was trying to do the biggest
difference that i see between kobe and
jordan is that jordan um i read this
article years ago where
it was basically
an interview of michael jordan and
michael jordan was talking about how
even till this day in his age he's still
like he he still feels like he could
just tear anybody up
and you know
like he's still talking [ __ ] in his head
yeah at his age of 60 or whatever he's
still like i'll [ __ ] this full of
popcorn which is so he hasn't found
peace yeah and i feel anyway from
reading this from from reading um
that uh that that piece of writing that
jordan still has unresolved things in
the sport he still feels like he needs
to do more even though he's the goat
which is crazy and kopi doesn't have
that kobe's like i did my piece i can
leave happy and people were even when
they were interviewing him they're like
would you ever think about playing again
he goes no i'm done yeah yeah you know
he he left it all in the court man yeah
and that that was a beautiful thing to
witness like for somebody to be as great
as kobe was to to find peace after he's
done with his career and tackle new
challenges and and to thrive in it and
then boom it's like it's gone you know
that's why i was so sad because it was
like
i don't know the guy personally but i
did grow up watching him and he he was a
part of my childhood and adulthood and
he inspired me on so many levels and to
see him you know tack like go on to
tackle new things was just it was
inspiring man and
again i didn't know him personally but i
felt happy for him too yeah
and then it's like yeah it's just
[ __ ] one morning you know it's like
he got in a helicopter right like one of
my favorite moments about this i said is
the last time we talked about it was
when everybody was like rick fox died
too
yeah you responded to it
i really don't know how his name got
caught up in the mix somebody just
didn't like breakfast and was like yeah
he died too
somebody somebody just hates rick fox
and he spread a [ __ ] rumor that he
was dead
fox was like i'm still alive
what are you talking about
i don't know why anybody would care
about rick fox on that level at this
point to even come up with that rumor
but yeah that was
despite it being a very tragic situation
i did find humor in that too that [ __ ] i
i felt i felt so [ __ ] do you remember
that there was uh was that the that
comic uh ari shafir he got canceled
because of some tweets that he said
about kobe or something like that no no
what happened [ __ ] i don't even remember
now but i think i talked about the
podcast years ago but that's like one of
those moments where there were some
people who made really good jokes that
kind of navigated in between the
borderline of like offensive and then
really [ __ ] funny yeah but
his joke wasn't really good i forgot the
one joke on twitter like when he died
that made me cry laughing yeah i can't
remember which one it was but there was
that was that weird borderline of like
damn this is really tragic but there's a
joke in this somewhere you know she was
[ __ ] she was [ __ ] crazy like i
still remember everything everybody
remembers where they were when he when
he died and when he passed away yeah
yeah now i remember distinctly man i was
in bed uh my my second office
why is my dick going soft right now
something
something happened in the world let me
look up the news right now
something's off yeah something
i'm getting bad vibes right here right
now yeah i don't just go limp for no
reason you know um no yeah i was i was
uh in bed and then uh my my ex woke me
up and was just like kobe died and not
you know i was kind of half asleep still
and i'm like what are you what are you
talking about yeah
we're talking about [ __ ] kobe you
know like what do you mean he died
and she's like yeah you know there's
like it's on the news like he died in a
helicopter crash and i was like what i
hella ignored it because you know what
it felt like it felt like that time when
i was super young and i remember when uh
news broke out that aliyah died
because i when when they when it was on
the when yeah at church people you know
you know leah died i thought everybody
was [ __ ] with me yeah and so i didn't
pay any attention to it yeah and then
three or four days later and people are
like yo aaliyah died i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] real dude yeah i
think i think that's how a lot of people
took it man they were just kind of in
disbelief at first like oh this has to
be one of those [ __ ] rumors i think
everybody was just kind of waiting for
confirmation that this did actually
happen because i think too my initial
thing was like nah man this is [ __ ]
kobe dude like what kind of sick joke is
this you know like come on we taking
this hoax to a whole different level now
i remember jordan when he heard the news
he was like i beat you
jordan
you know what though like this the dudes
need to compete is like on a psychotic
it's crazy yeah yeah he's like maniacal
when it comes to the need to compete so
i would
i wouldn't put it past him if he had
that private talk did you did you so i
mean this happened a while ago but i
didn't really talk about did you listen
to young dolph
um no i'm like
barely aware of it only know of his name
yeah exactly but i didn't listen to any
of his music to be honest with you yeah
but
he got murdered which was yeah which was
[ __ ] crazy i saw i didn't read too
much about it yeah but then he got
murdered while he was picking up cookies
right which is some story that i would
hear about myself or something and
apparently there was like a there's a
conspiracy theory about it being a setup
that from the cookie store yes the owner
of the cookie store being involved with
his murderer in some way i was like yo
man i know you like that chocolate chip
cookie because apparently the cookie
owner the cookie store owner was like
saying he wasn't present at the time
young dolph died or got shot and killed
or whatever
but
other
reports are saying that he was holding
young dolph
as he was dying
so people were kind of like yo whoa hold
up hold up what's going on here this
whole baited him with cookies and killed
him that's the craziest story i've ever
heard in my life i don't know what's
going on i mean
like i said it's a theory it's a
conspiracy theory but apparently there's
some inconsistencies and the details of
what happened for some reason i just
pictured this really fat guy with an
apron like i'm the [ __ ] cookie
killer
he just invites young dog over you
trying to get this chocolate chips on
it's like what's what's this beef with
him what's his beef with young dolphins
like macadamias and his cookies and then
he was like you don't like macadamia
cookies you're dead
you're [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know i
heard too though i heard he he
uh promoted that small business so like
supported and everything really okay so
that's why it's a little weird to me
because i read a i read a small piece in
the article what they were talking about
he used to shout he shouted out this
business all the time yeah it was like
his favorite cookie spot and then he was
kind of involved in that of like blowing
that spot up because he would always
talk about yo i got to get up and get my
cookies from the spot which is kind of
weird maybe it's a front maybe it's a
front for something and some business
deal went bad you know what i mean
i'm so curious now but i don't know all
this all this weird stuff too like you
know i think we used to say or i i said
multiple times on this podcast work
uh i feel that a lot of gang violence
has like died down compared to like the
90s but they're still [ __ ] dangerous
look man
don't get it twisted there's still
very active gang members that are out
there it's just again not a part of pop
culture
cultural stream media in 90s it was like
it was a cool thing to do so even if you
weren't part of that environment or
whatever people still dress like it talk
like it listen to like gangster rap and
all that but now it's not
so-called like cool to be a gangster you
know what i mean uh but those people who
are living in the hood growing up in
that type of environment where it might
even be generational like their grandpa
wasn't that gang and their dad was in
that gang and now they're in the gang
it was [ __ ] crazy so literally a
couple days ago i actually
i had this random [ __ ] memory yeah
that just popped up because i was having
a conversation with a friend of mine uh
from sacramento he came to visit
but
he reminded me of the story that i
completely forgot because it was [ __ ]
traumatizing so you suppress this
champion
back up i suppress this [ __ ] memory
super [ __ ] hard but he was talking to
me about like he's like you know we were
just kind of sharing in conversation
about where we're at right now so
he is now a pharmacist right super dope
and this guy was like the dumbest
[ __ ] person i ever knew in my life
and he you know
you know who the [ __ ] you are stupid
[ __ ]
he was stupid but i'm proud of you bro
he was stupid as hell he was such a
goofy stupid [ __ ] guy and i think he
and i were both in this weird situation
where we always wanted to be something
that we weren't you know it's that time
when we were talking about where gang
violence was very glamorized so even
though we didn't belong in these circles
we wanted to be on the periphery of it
we wanted to you know just be a part of
that type of [ __ ] but we weren't really
about this life so he reminded me of
that time
he was like hey remember that one time
that full [ __ ] checked your ass super
hard i was like what are you talking
about so there was this uh specific uh
gang that i used to not kick it with per
se but they allowed me to kick it with
them because i grew up with one of the
og's younger brothers okay and
it's it's funny but it's not funny
because
i think they liked me because i was a
really goofy funny [ __ ] guy right so
i always like crack jokes or whatever
but there is a hierarchy in terms of who
you get to make fun of in the club oh
yeah for sure
right you don't just to get just to
clown on everybody you don't get an
instant pass exactly like the og ogs
they have a lot of [ __ ] pride and
this is back in the day where you know
especially as thugs emotions aren't a
part of the [ __ ] equation you you
can't just [ __ ] clown on one of the
og's make fun of them and then you're
going to walk away scratch free yeah so
i was allowed to kick it with them and i
was like a bigger dude too so i kind of
looked like one of the older guys but i
wasn't i was just a six-month-old you
know at the age of 14. yeah
and uh you know we were joking around
whatever and then this the homies older
brother he was saying some [ __ ] and i
think that
when i look back at it now i think he
was trying to imitate me because i would
make a lot of jokes and people would
crack up so he wanted to be a funny guy
too the guy wasn't [ __ ] funny at all
i can say this now he doesn't do any of
that stuff he's a super nice guy now has
kids has family but you know what you
did to me
um
he's super [ __ ] nice like he's super
cool and chill you know just at that
time it was a different era
i actually don't know what he does but
his younger brother's a pharmacist but
he um
i was getting a little too comfortable
and you know cracking jokes or whatever
and then he made a joke and this is in
front of all the all the homies or
whatever and i'm one of the tongue twins
and i'm just like
i can't remember the joke that i said
but i was basically making fun of him
that he's not funny but he's trying so
hard to be and people started laughing
and you know you know when somebody
laughs but they're not really laughing
yeah he just doesn't want to seem like
he can't take a joke right he's like
hahaha whatever what not right and then
one of the homies kind of looked at me
like oh [ __ ]
like bro you [ __ ] up man i got carried
away you know because i felt super
comfortable because they allowed me to
kick it with them
and then this will straight up
in the middle of nowhere out of out of
nowhere as we're like people are
laughing or whatever he's like oh you
think you're [ __ ] funny huh and i'm i
don't i'm oblivious i'm just giggling
and laughing and he's like blah blah
blah he's like would you giggle if i
[ __ ] kept you right now and this full
[ __ ] flashes piece at me and he
flashes piece at me legit like this and
then people are like kind of laugh
they're laughing still right because
they could tell he's pissed at me like i
can't tell yeah and i'm like i'm like
what the [ __ ] you ain't to shoot me and
this will literally takes his [ __ ] uh
piece and he puts it on my thigh
and then
i got
i remember like the blood uh just like
draining from my flesh your body man
just left your body i don't know if
anybody has ever felt this but when you
face like real fear it feels like all
the the blood in your [ __ ] face just
dissipates and you're just pale and it's
like a cold sweat right and i remember
he put that [ __ ] gun to my thigh like
joking around whatever but then i'm a
kid and i have a gun next to my [ __ ]
dick yeah you know i said what if i shot
your dick off saying [ __ ] like this and
he's laughing but he's laughing but he's
also kind of serious yeah and i remember
just freaked the [ __ ] out right and then
he's like look at this [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] you know he's scared he's like
go [ __ ] shoot you but he would he
would have shot me yeah and i remember i
went home and i [ __ ] cried dude
oh man i went home yeah that night just
out of nowhere i started [ __ ] crying
because i was like i could have died
right and i was like dude remember when
your [ __ ] brother did that to me he
was like yo brother your brother put a
[ __ ] piece to my [ __ ] thigh and my
dick he goes yeah he's not like that
anymore man like he's like super like
everybody else remembers it as a funny
moment except for me
because you're the one traumatizing i
was traumatizing [ __ ] everybody was
giggling laughing or whatever but this
will [ __ ] check my gangster it's
super [ __ ] hard to put a [ __ ] gun
to my dick
and i'm like oh my god dude it was uh
the goodfellas joe pesci moment oh you
think i'm [ __ ] funny yeah yeah but i
didn't die you know
it's like one of those days i shut the
[ __ ] up paulie what was that boom he
kills him
but literally that dude [ __ ]
threatened me oh just because i hurt his
ego and his pride well but but that's
the thing you had to learn that lesson
the hard way
i mean
did you wrong i know i know but but you
also as as traumatized yet as it was you
got to be thankful you got to pass like
that because it could have been a lot
more different it beat my ass yeah if
exactly at the very least he could have
just beat your ass you could gotta jump
for that [ __ ] you know what i mean and
like he could have targeted you
every time he sees you now like you're
that dude they're gonna bomb on he
wasn't going to because [ __ ] this
full told his brother that i cried
why did you tell me why did you tell
your friend that you cried then well
because he called me up see if i was
cool
i was like y'all
because we were on the phone yeah i
don't want to tell this part but i will
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore we were on
the phone and i was like yo you cool man
like i'm sorry you know my brother
[ __ ] pulled that piece on you and as
he was talking to me i started crying
thinking about it
it's like oh [ __ ]
i was like
i was like kind of pissed at him i was
like bro your brother could have killed
me he wasn't gonna kill you man so
you're my homie dude he's not gonna [ __ ]
he just wanted to you know check your
gangster or whatever what not i'm like
i'm for but he was so much older too i
was like well that's the age gap how old
was he uh he definitely
was
he wasn't in high school okay but oh
okay he was older than yeah he didn't go
to college so i don't know what he was
exactly but i think he was at least like
19 or 20. okay so obviously a 14 year
old makes a joke at you and then
yeah especially if he's an og or
whatever oh dude you are stepping on
toes like a [ __ ] i think for him
too like when i look at it it's like
you know what's like what's that word in
korean it's like
you know
you think you would you could say yeah
yeah right one of those things yeah
because he was always super nice to me
yeah so i thought that we could just
joke but i think that if it was in a
setting of just me his brother and him
it would have been fine but it was me
his brother and him and like five of the
dukes right right and so i didn't know
that the the social hierarchy of the
[ __ ] and i think for me because i wasn't
in the gang it wasn't a gang thing to me
i was just at my friend's house yeah
with his older brother yeah everybody
just it's all shits and giggles you
thought you know it's all good why not
i'm gonna crack a joke
oh [ __ ] guess how many times i went back
to his house after that
zero times
did you ever talk to his brother after
that he was super nice to me okay
okay and i think for him too i think he
felt bad yeah i think he felt bad after
he found out i went home and i cried so
he's a gangster with a conscience yeah
well he's he saw me since i was a little
kid yeah you know what i mean so it's
not like he just wanted to do that [ __ ]
but i think for him within his power in
that group he had to do what he had to
do to show everybody like yo this kid's
not gonna just go ahead and mouth off to
me how the [ __ ] he wants right because i
was a funny guy
but that [ __ ] was traumatizing you gotta
know man there's there's rules like
unspoken rules and things you gotta know
in that type of environment that type of
setting and hierarchy and that's a no-no
right there man
you committed cardinal sin i didn't
[ __ ] know i wish you would have told
me
what's it gonna say like hey you could
joke but be careful who you joking yes i
would have liked that specific
instruction like yo you know how we
clown each other don't ever do that in
front of the homies like you gotta know
your place he never said that to me no i
know but i'm saying like in the moment
it happened it's already too late you
know what i mean
i'm over here just
i'm like half at the top of my life
you know what i'm saying just laughing
my ass off whatever what not and it was
problematic too because at 14 i was
drinking and then you know they were
giving me drinks so i was already super
loose and [ __ ] drunk
as a 14 year old kid
that's probably why i cried at home too
because i was drunk well look man if you
weren't used to being in that
environment completely understandable
completely understanding i'll tell you
this i never did it again
i kept my mouth shut at least you
learned your lesson
i guess it worked
i never went back to that house ever
again do you want to know the [ __ ]
funny thing about the story too this is
the funniest part about it yeah they're
he's awesome their family is also like
devout catholic so
what this what this happened are they
filipino by each other vietnamese
they're such devout catholic he did this
[ __ ] while we were in his garage in
front of the house yeah
and but they it was for lent so they
couldn't eat meat so they were they
barbecued they're barbecuing [ __ ]
fish sticks
they're barbecuing fish sticks because
that was the only thing that they had
without any meat so it was a bunch of
heinekens and these fools were grilling
fish sticks why not just fish why is it
gonna be fish they didn't have it they
just had fish things but for some reason
they they brought out the [ __ ] weber
and they were grilling fish sticks on it
dog
i've never
seen anybody grill fresh fish sticks on
a [ __ ] boat they were literally
grilling fish sticks on this like mini
weber grill yeah i just had a gun to my
[ __ ] dick with bunch of heinekens
drinking dude
this whole scenario is the [ __ ]
funniest thing ever
and that's so funny how you suppress
that memory until you saw that guy
you're like remember that time your
[ __ ] brother pointed a gun at my dick
doug there was this other memory
so
i was talking to my cousin
and um
my cousin told me this [ __ ] where
uh we were hanging out with each other
this was like maybe a year ago i might
have already told this but it was a year
ago where we were it was me my cousin
and my uh i think no it wasn't my
brother it was me and my cousin i think
it was just us we were in sacramento and
we decided to drive by our old duplexes
so
in sacramento we used to live in these
duplexes and
uh my cousin and my aunt and uncle they
lived in a duplex pretty close by in the
same neighborhood
this podcast is brought to you by raycon
my friends by now you've probably seen
about a thousand gift guides for the
holiday season gifts for moms gifts for
guys gifts for your neighbors cousins
dog who you don't like but you know what
might as well just throw that stupid
[ __ ] in there pooped on my lawn the
other day you could study all those gift
guys and shop at 10 different places or
you could just stop your shopping and
just go to raycon and get a gift
everyone will use we all know how much
we hate gifts that have no freaking
purpose if you give somebody a sweater
for a christmas gift just know there's a
special place in hell for you you piece
of [ __ ]
my aunt raycon gives you amazing audio
quality wherever you go we're talking
about raycon wireless earbuds whether
you use them to pump up wind down to
work out or anything else everybody
loves themselves a pair of raycons i
love mine i just came back from the gym
when i was
boxing and guess what my raycon earbuds
didn't fall out they caressed my ear
holes like it like uh like my wife
caresses my butt yeah i said it the
holidays are coming up faster than you
think now is the time to knock out that
gift list and avoid the last minute
shipping scramble especially because
right now my listeners will get fifteen
percent off site wide with code holiday
at byraycon.com brain go to buy recon
dot com slash brain and use code holiday
to get fifteen percent off your entire
recon order that's by raycon.com
brain
b-r-a-i-n
in this neighborhood
it's a bunch of trap houses
it's not a very nice neighborhood yeah
we um
we see in a lot of like neighborhood
fights as little kids
i remember this specific memory where we
we all got into this huge fight
and
this is one random memory of a of a lady
at the block just watching us fight each
other
i was like whoa
oh this is actually your hair it might
be i don't know oh my goodness but
we're at this duplex i forgot what the
reason was but we had this whole little
like neighborhood block brawl all the
kids were fighting each other i don't
know what the [ __ ] it was about yeah but
this one specific memory of this lady
standing there and my cousin remembers
this too he goes do you remember when we
were doing that neighborhood fight and
all the kids were fighting each other
and it was one of the ladies who was
just standing there watching us eating
pink starburst
she was just sitting there eating pink
starbursts i was like yo i [ __ ]
remember this and then i told them i go
hey remember that one crazy kid where he
broke up the fight because he came
through and he pulled out a knife on
everybody like a kitchen knife he ran
into the house and he grabbed the
kitchen knife and started swinging it at
people wow to stop the fight yeah no to
like [ __ ] people up oh to [ __ ] people oh
he was engaged in the fight yeah he was
like trying to [ __ ] stab people like
a kitchen knife wow
and my cousin stops and he looks at me
and he goes are you serious i'm like
yeah you remember that [ __ ] crazy kid
who was like trying to stab people yeah
he goes bro that was you
that was like
oh my cracking up i'm like
nah yeah no that was somebody else he
goes
he goes are you are you serious he goes
that was you
you're out of body mode he was like you
were the one that grabbed the [ __ ]
kitchen knife and started swinging it at
people because [ __ ] was getting crazy
because you did that i'm like no no that
was not me with somebody else
because i was so [ __ ] scared because
you were trying to stab people with a
[ __ ] kitchen knife yeah i'm like i
don't remember this at all i remember
the moment but i remember it being
somebody else
that's crazy isn't that [ __ ] nuts
yeah that's crazy and i thought this was
[ __ ] with me but it was confirmed
with a couple of other people were there
they're like bro that was you you were
the one that brought the you ran into
the [ __ ] house and you just came out
with a kitchen knife you started
swinging it at everybody well how old
are you at this point uh if i was living
at the duplex i had to be seven years
old damn
you thought it was a good idea to grab a
kitchen knife yeah well [ __ ] was getting
[ __ ] crazy yeah but i just
i don't remember being the one who did
that but i remember somebody else did
yeah but it's kind of crazy how your
memory can rewire because at this point
i feel like i'm telling the truth yeah
if three other people say otherwise
they're probably right that's a that's
trippy for sure because like you know i
did something similar too where um i
grabbed the [ __ ] katana uh from the
house that's the most asian thing yeah
i've never heard about it i know i know
but it was you know how like the katana
like i think our family received it as
like a gift or something and you know
how there's a set with like the small
katana and the bikitana the small one
was big enough for me to like carry
properly yeah and then yeah i got into
some [ __ ] so i i went home i grabbed
that [ __ ] put it put it across my
shoulder and i got on my bike and i'm
like oh this motherfucker's dead that's
hella funny yeah did you cut somebody up
with me no i did it i pulled it out but
the parents came out you know oh and
they're like yo what yeah like what
all right take it easy samurai jack the
[ __ ] these asian people are [ __ ]
crazy
there was this uh there was
if you guys grew up in a semi ghetto
neighborhood you'll have fight stories
for days like so
in our neighborhood uh
it was about
right next to our my old elementary
school isabelle jackson there was a bus
stop that would get that would pick up
kids that to go to the junior high james
rutter right there was this uh one kid
that was an african kid and he used to
get bullied and picked on because he had
a thick [ __ ] accent uh i think he was
like from ghana or something like that
okay
but you know when you're a kid and there
wasn't many african kids in our school
yeah there was maybe a handful is his
name kamara
uzman right
it
so there was a kid in school that used
to bully him a lot at that bus stop all
the [ __ ] time now if you're asking
david why did you stand up for him i was
too busy getting bullied myself
so i can only do so much like it's hard
when people are hitting me yeah i'm like
listen i gotta make sure i don't get my
ass beat this [ __ ] was crazy this guy i
remember he used to get picked on all
the time and they would just say a bunch
of these african jokes at him right
these are all just a bunch of broke poor
kids
so this full
that day it was wearing a bunch of thick
clothes clothing like thick pants like a
puff jacket or whatever right
and
this full
started punking him again and then you
could tell like this it was not gonna
happen yeah this full starts stripping
right he starts taking off his jacket i
remember he had a jacket like a sweater
inside everybody's like yo this [ __ ]
african's getting naked yo he's
stripping naked yeah and we don't know
what the [ __ ] is about to happen he
starts taking off everything he's just
like in his shirt or like a tank top or
whatever my memory is fuzzy now about it
but it was like a shirt let's just say
it's a shirt he's like in his shirt now
and then he starts taking off his belt
we're like this fool's about to show his
dick takes off his belt throws it down
right starts undoing his pants yeah and
this out of nowhere
pulls out a table leg
from his pants
at the table a [ __ ] table or like a
chair leg or some [ __ ] right but you
could tell it was from a piece of
furniture right and then you see this
fool
his i'll say this i'll say his first
thing was derived so doris's eyes just
goes wide and i remember this [ __ ]
like it was it was slow-mo he goes no
today madifoca comes up and just
what darius turns around tries to run
yeah hits him in like the small of his
back hit the right back arches
beating his ass with this stick out of
nowhere
legit
[Music]
crazy dude he was ready man he came
ready he came ready and then everybody
screaming like yo what the [ __ ] this
fool's crazy the bus comes in people are
screaming bus drivers telling everybody
to get inside the bus
go inside the bus the african kid i wish
i remember his name but he just walked
in the last person that walked in the
bus sat in the front
crossed his arms and just sat there
didn't say what did he do at the table
like huh he i don't i don't know what he
did with him
he was either back in his pants or some
[ __ ]
get rid of the [ __ ] the murder weapon
right i still remember that phrase not
today muddy [ __ ]
that's so g though bro
that's so g man bro if you guys know
african people right the way they would
whoop their kids with table legs and
belts and these [ __ ] too like i
remember something popped off in twitter
right but it was like a fight that
happened like in africa or something and
it was like a world star video but these
fools had belts that they were whipping
each other with and sticks and i got
tagged in that [ __ ] because everybody
was like oh that story that david told
was true i was like i told you this
brought a [ __ ] table like a chairman
and he started beating the [ __ ] out of
this kid that's the thing though when
you're in an environment without [ __ ]
guns you use whatever the [ __ ] you can
to to get
whatever you can get your hands on
that's going to do the most damage and
harm possible whether it be your belt
whether it be a table leg a bicycle tire
whatever is in the environment you know
i've never seen somebody beat the [ __ ]
out of somebody with a table leg dude
that reminds me of the story of stephon
marbury you know the basketball player
yeah star berries baby yeah starving
forward
debuted his shoe that he sprayed his
ankle
garbage i mean look i admire why he made
the star berries because he wanted to
like make affordable shoes for kids in
the in inner city right but like yeah i
remember a story he was telling too like
about the all the crazy [ __ ] that he
would see growing up and one of the
stories was he saw a dude get impaled by
a table leg on the basketball court
a fight broke out and somebody got
[ __ ] stabbed and impaled by a table
leg and i thought it was just
like who has a sharp [ __ ] table leg
just out there at the ready you know
it's like african too that kid 100
percent 100 percent that's what was that
good man he's like you know he moved to
new york after he got older [ __ ]
you are telling me i don't get these
books
i get buckets i bet you it was the same
dude
i mean
when i was in sacramento everybody told
me i couldn't do nothing and he just
comes up to start stabbing people on the
court now there's so many questions
behind that like
yesterday i saw a [ __ ] homeless dude
with a vacuum and i said why the [ __ ]
does he have a vacuum same [ __ ] why does
he have a table like where did he get
the table leg from did he break it up
did he just happen to find it how did he
fit it into his pants without making it
seem like there's a [ __ ] table like
going down you know what i mean there
was just so many questions so many weird
uh
everything that i thought was kind of
normal
growing like growing up when you kept
when you share stories with others for
sure for sure and their eyes are wide
i'm like for sure that's not normal yeah
yeah no yeah no you definitely have
those moments like when you
start growing up start interacting with
uh people from different walks of life
and and you guys are sharing stories
and then you have that moment of like
oh you didn't grow up like that yeah you
didn't go through that okay like having
there was this one kid in our junior
high that flunked like two or three
times or some [ __ ] this was hella old
i'm like the [ __ ] are you do still doing
here bro like you could get a job now
and it feels like in junior high
and nobody would [ __ ] with that fool
because like he was like
his
i'm not sure if he was but he was on the
way to be a norteno because his you know
his whole family's affiliated yeah
because he would he would always get in
trouble because uh we had school
uniforms but he would always wear a red
rag with them all the time and you're
not supposed to wear rags with colors
right but he didn't give a [ __ ] right
because like he i guess he wanted to be
hard as [ __ ] yeah but this i'm like bro
you're like
25 years old and you're in junior high
dog like get the [ __ ] out of here bro it
wasn't that all but i'm just saying like
he's old as [ __ ] it's like that and
obviously he's gonna be bigger i would
assume then he was bigger dude yeah than
the kids if he's [ __ ] two three years
older like during that time that makes a
pretty big difference the musculature
looks different too yeah you know
because we just hit puberty and then we
go into junior high and then you see
this [ __ ] there it's like bro
you clearly don't belong here yeah
methyl used to have like the gel back
hair and he used to braid that [ __ ] up
like his hair was hella [ __ ] long
yeah and he used to wear his pants as
baggy as [ __ ] possible yeah sag that
[ __ ] red boxers red bandana and he used
to always get in trouble for that [ __ ]
but nobody would [ __ ] with him because
he's so much older yeah well i mean you
would be kind of stupid like to
say anything to him make fun of them
like somebody
god
but yo speaking of guns man i know this
is a kind of a hard segue here but the
uh whole like school shooting situation
again you know happening ethan crumbly
bro what happened with that i actually
didn't read it because i was like
i just didn't want to yeah no so
basically it's another math school
shooting um this kid ethan crumbly it
happened in michigan and
the [ __ ] up part is like you know once
details came out about the situation
after it happened it was completely
preventable right now his parents are
also in i believe in custody being
charged with the involuntary
manslaughter what like they got like
four charges against them but
the kid's mom
bought him a [ __ ] gun for his 15th
birthday i believe right and that day
that the shooting happened
he drew apparently some very disturbing
pictures of like him killing people or
something just something very graphic
teachers saw it they had a conference
with the parents
that day
and it was so alarming that i think they
advised the parents like hey this guy
needs to seek professional help within
the next 48 hours right okay if it's
that alarming where you say within the
next 48 within the next two days this
guy needs to get some help right
but you know what they did after that
they sent him right back to class what
and you know what happened after that
people died people got shot people got
hurt
completely preventable and look
when i saw
that this happened
my first instinct
was just ah
or my first reaction sorry was
another mass shooting yeah yeah yeah but
then i caught myself this time where i
hated that i was having that reaction
i'm like [ __ ] man i'm so desensitized to
these mass shootings to these [ __ ]
children getting shot and killed and
dying that my reaction is oh another
mass shooting you know we we i had this
thought too where
uh there's a lot of news now
um but we where we always kind of harp
on this too it's that the the media that
we get fed that a lot of people harp and
talk big about are the ones that are
pushed towards us right there is no
denying this anymore yeah right
uh we talk about that with the uh
the giselle um
delaine
yeah yeah whatever just delay maxwell
gillane max giselle
elaine maxwell right that's a huge
[ __ ] case yeah it's getting no
coverage i know nobody gives a [ __ ] i
know and [ __ ] we're talking about
[ __ ] miners in this case too you know
and so with this man i just i kind of
stopped myself you know i mean as you
know it's been like crazy and busy and
hectic for me lately but i just stopped
myself to like
really let myself feel it you know and i
was just thinking about i mean [ __ ]
think about it dude the heartbreak your
friend died your child died your your
nephew died your niece you know what i
mean and and
these are [ __ ] kids
right and what does that say about like
the state of this country and the state
of gun law like you want me to tell you
something crazy bro our country the
united states of america right
from what i remember i don't know if
this stat has been updated but i think
as of 2018
our country is has 60 times more
mass school shootings than all the
developed nations combined
what the [ __ ] does that say about the
state of our country what does that say
about the state of our society we're
talking about kids
the fact that they're kids implies they
need nurturing they need guidance they
need help right
they're kids who
basically you got to teach them how to
navigate this world
his parents failed him
the school system failed him and society
failed him i wonder too in like these
cases too right
uh
i wonder what the stat is for other
countries
because there's a lot of stuff that
isn't said or done right just because
like
not in terms of like mass shootings or
whatever yeah but
because
i always like for example i had a
conversation with somebody where we were
talking about all these stories that we
would hear in mexico like stuff would
happen and i've shared a story on this
podcast where i talked about a a girl
who was kidnapped by the cartel had her
body chopped off in half and delivered
yeah you know yeah and then just
recently i talked to another buddy of
mine who had a person who was in film a
friend and then he was missing for three
days they didn't know where the [ __ ] he
was yeah he went to a [ __ ] resort in
mexico got kidnapped by a competing
cartel i don't i don't remember which
resort it was and then he was like
tortured for three days right they took
all of his [ __ ] money i'm like holy
[ __ ] yeah this world is [ __ ] savage
savage this was like a year ago or
something like that that's pretty
[ __ ] recent dude yeah and he was at a
resort yeah which is not supposed to
happen at resorts right um which is kind
of shocking too but you know to go back
on that
i wonder if a columbine happened now
would people care as much as they did
back then right i wonder right because
there was that massacre in vegas where
there was like a sniper on a building
just yeah [ __ ] killing yeah he's
going off it was like one of the biggest
mass shootings in history yeah but
people don't talk about that you know
and that but that's what i'm saying you
just get desensitized to this thing you
know and look there's gonna be people
like oh you know but that kid was just
crazy or hey he had bad parents what we
don't have um
mental health uh issues in other
countries we don't have bad parents in
other countries that exists all across
the world the difference is the access
to guns
other countries either don't have it or
it's extremely [ __ ] hard to get it
right so
i think that's like a reflection of of
like what needs to change in this
country man like
look the the people having guns it's all
fine and good but don't make it easy for
them to get it you know yeah i mean
that's definitely the parent's fault
though like yeah
absolutely his parents are [ __ ]
garbage it's clear they fled too once
they became people of interest they they
disappeared you know and they had to get
arrested
yeah because i think they found out that
there might they might be facing some
charges here yeah you gave a 15 year old
a [ __ ] gun yeah well and just
negligence all around yeah you know
that's what i'm saying the parents
failed them the school system failed
them the society failed but that kind of
just goes up man how how shitty those
parents are because you could tell
after their kid just did a mass [ __ ]
shooting did that kid survive by the way
yeah yeah so he didn't kill himself no
uh he and he's getting tried as an adult
okay yeah so this mass shooting happens
right the parents aren't even thinking
about their kid they're thinking about
themselves right which goes to show a
reflection of how shitty exactly parents
are exactly sure i mean for me too i
think like the hard part is like
for anybody who talks about guns
i think the the the harsh reality that
everybody has to realize you're not
going to take guns away from americans
it's just not going to happen right it's
like what the foundation of this country
was brought upon it has to deal with you
know in case government takes control
it's just ingrained in our culture and
society i think the hard part is like
individual responsibility is kind of um
not really focused on right you go oh we
need we need to um
take all these guns away just not
possible so let's talk about something a
little more real right gun loss like
yeah and that's i wish i knew more about
like the whole gun situation in this
country um
because i i really don't well gun gun
gun rights activists want to make it as
simple as possible to be able to not
only own a firearm but to be able to
carry the firearm concealed firearm all
of that right yeah but i'm just saying
it's like why is it so hard to [ __ ]
agree on the fact that it should be a
very very extensive process in order for
you to be able to buy a firearm possess
a firearm and own it yeah i wonder what
the argument behind that is i never
really thought about it because
that's why that's why it's really that
it's really it's it's our god-given
right it's in the it's the second
amendment the right to bear arms right
california too is like a really weird
place to be right now just because
recently if you guys heard um there's a
bunch of smash and grabs people getting
uh robbed in front of their house it's
it's it's
it's crazy it's what the annoying thing
is is that these people are getting
caught and just let go like with with no
not being recommended at all yeah let me
tell you something funny about that so
uh you know the whole defund the police
campaign yeah yeah i believe lapd had
lost 150 million in in uh in funding and
then now they got more than that they
got 200 million
because people saw oh [ __ ] we need cops
so look man even the whole defund the
police [ __ ] i'm not against [ __ ]
police reform and there needs to be a
lot more rules and procedures in place
that's um
i guess more universal across the board
but
defund the police just as a general
thing all right just take money away
from
that ain't solving [ __ ] bro but you know
what the funny thing is people people
can't even also admit wrong because i
remember i also talked about like you
know
uh
giving it a different moniker or like
reallocate this you know but
i had a couple of conversations with uh
people that i met that are cops right
and
they they kind of gave me a different
perspective of like
how guns are dealt with and how like
these situations are dealt with right
they go oh you should call social
workers he goes you ask a social worker
who wants to go into a dangerous
situation and you let me know who that
social worker is right it's a lot easier
said than done um and this buddy was
like
you think i wouldn't want somebody else
to go in there besides me to deal with
these [ __ ] a crazy person with the
weapon who wants to kill themselves and
kill everybody you think i wouldn't mind
having somebody else say hey i could do
your job better and it's a social worker
yeah guess what that social worker
doesn't want to go there
10 out of 10 times yeah they're going to
say no i was like you know what you want
to know why because a 50 000 job isn't
worth wasting your life for yeah exactly
so he goes
people keep telling us about these
situations where they don't know our job
and they also don't know the situations
he goes yeah they're i agree with these
situations with these [ __ ] cops they
don't represent the force that i know so
i get it and i understand the hard part
is that everybody's keep everybody keeps
throwing out these solutions that are
way easier said than done so when we
talk about reallocating this money to
social workers they go what are you
talking about yeah they don't want to be
there yeah i go oh and i was like oh
[ __ ] you know what you're kind of right
i don't
i don't think as a social worker i would
want to do that like does this entail my
job yeah like and does it pay reflected
as well yeah so we have to talk about
that too it's like there's it's a deeper
issue than a lot of people think you
know
and um i talked to another buddy of mine
um
who i forgot that he was a cop you know
for the longest because we don't ever
talk about his work
but he was talking about like the
difficulty with
dealing with
so many people in so many cases
that it's just a really hard job and
like for example he goes i would watch
cases where people are getting mad about
how people are handled he goes have you
ever tried to restrain somebody before
when they're when they're being
belligerent or on drugs or on drugs
because none of you know what that
[ __ ] feels like he goes it feels like
you're trying to wrestle somebody that
has super human strength he goes it's
so [ __ ] hard he had his uh he had to
get uh like surgery on his back because
somebody like ripped out and like
dislocated like a couple of his discs um
he got [ __ ] up quite a few times and
he goes and even in those cases people
are screaming like why are you hurting
him he goes i i got like three of my
vertebrae's popped out you know what i
mean
for this guy who was going around uh
beating his wife and so we had a
restraint and then people are screaming
you know this i'm a piece of [ __ ] cop
when i came in for a domestic violence
call but nobody talks to me about this
stuff you know he goes i understand that
there's bad cops but we never get to see
the full scope of things it's like we
we're very needed in this community and
it makes it hard to work this job when
people tell you that you're [ __ ]
useless that's what i'm saying though
it's the over generalizing yeah grouping
everybody into the same thing and saying
oh you know what you're a [ __ ] cop
you're a bad guy nah man just like
everything else there's good people and
there's bad people you know not all
[ __ ] cops are evil and [ __ ] want
to harm people or like you know racially
profile or you know use uh violence or
excessive for nah man it's not not all
[ __ ] cops are like that you know but
we live in an age where it's just like
they want a screenshot of what is the
general thing we're talking about here
and then just run with that okay you
know what we're gonna we're talking
about defunding the police defund the
[ __ ] police everywhere nobody wanted
to take responsibility for the fact
where people were like um somebody
mentioned to you where i was talking
about reallocating money and they're
like david you're dumb because that's
what defund the police means i was like
no that's what it became because of the
criticism it was not like that at first
it was defund and take money away you
decided to redefine it now because you
realize how stupid it was and now you're
trying to act like you're smarter than
everybody else when really that
definition changes later on which i
didn't [ __ ] know about you know what
i'm saying and listen i'm you know when
we get caught up in our emotions like
i'm guilty of this too where yeah well
i'll defund the police when i first
heard that i was like that's a great
solution but then all it took for me was
to take a step back and say maybe we
should reallocate this money and do this
this and that then i talked to like
two cop buddies of mine and they both
said the same thing it's easier said
than done and they both gave me the same
reason they don't know each other i'm
like [ __ ] that's another perspective i
didn't think about it it's a complex
issue man there's there's no way around
that and and i think again the problem
is is that people are just over
generalizing too much on what needs to
be fixed but yeah it's clear bro like
all the [ __ ] that's been happening in la
you know the crazy thing is like we've
been seeing the
uh
all the crimes happening in rich parts
of l.a right melrose beverly hills
places like that
difference is though
they they still got money so you know
what they do they say oh you know what
we're tired of this [ __ ] happening so
they banted banded together residents
right they bought cameras and set up
cameras everywhere and now they have
like a private security business going
on
do that [ __ ]
in in a you know like yeah in a poor
area that's not going to happen they
just have to live with it right
so it's another thing just the disparity
in in [ __ ] wealth and just kind of
this the whole situation here in l.a has
gone to absolute [ __ ] to the point where
like i don't even know if i want to live
in l.a anymore yeah i mean it's getting
to that point for me now too especially
because of how elite you know the
hardest thing about california is the
way that they
i consider myself pretty liberal he's
getting crazy now you know what i mean
like the fact that criminals are getting
away and they're getting benefits versus
being reprimanded it's like oh i could
just smash and grab something under a
thousand dollars or under five thousand
dollars and i could walk away scratch
free there's no consequences for people
i'll tell you this though you know a lot
of people not my like the the gun laws
in texas you rob somebody in texas
you're [ __ ] six feet under yeah you
know well so that's an argument for
like gun advocates right and again i'm
not saying oh take away everybody's guns
and people don't have the right to own
no i'm not saying that i'm just saying
there just needs to be a lot more
extensive it needs to be a lot more
extensive process to getting a gun it
shouldn't be an easy process by no means
because
you got these people who are not right
in the head whether they're old enough
to buy it or these irresponsible parents
[ __ ] purchasing a gun for their kid
who's already mentally unstable for his
15th birthday and at what's the result
yeah what was the what was the [ __ ]
idea behind that it's like ah my kid's a
little crazy
a gun
you know
i want to know the [ __ ] thought
process behind that well obviously
they're trash human beings man i mean
i i don't know like the the details of
like everything in that case with the
parents but just from what i've read i'm
like dude what are you doing bro yeah
like what are you [ __ ] doing and it's
just
ah
like i was thinking man if that was my
son my daughter my niece my nephew you
know like
it's heartbreaking man it's [ __ ]
heartbreaking and and it made me upset
and sad and angry all at the same time
just had like this bundle of emotion and
i'm like well [ __ ] man
uh it's another one of those stats where
this country is number one in and it's
not anything to be proud of you know
um so
that speaking of like liberal and all of
that this hat i was telling you before
we started the podcast so this is the
first time i wore this hat out in public
today and i was getting double takes
from people and i was like what the [ __ ]
why are like multiple people giving me
like double looks i think it was because
they thought i was wearing a mega hat
which is [ __ ] hilarious and you know
like red has become pretty much like i
like synonymous with the donald trump
brand and so i think they were just kind
of doing double takes to see if i had
and then they pointed out maybe they
thought it was m for mega yeah i'm like
this is not a m dude this is ss right
here for our secret society like you
feel good about yourself you [ __ ]
ass traitor hey so this hat is inspired
by a 90 cigarette i'm not going to say
the name you know because i don't want
to get in trouble but it's inspired by a
90 cigarette brand that should be clear
enough on what it's inspired by but i'm
like i wanted to tell these people i'm
not [ __ ] magabro
just people walk by why don't you suck
his dick
you're like what are you talking to me
what do you mean yeah it's so weird like
you know i was uh because i was going to
ups to drop off some stuff and then like
yeah people just kind of like
you know can't wear red hats anymore bro
i know but [ __ ] it bro like this is not
what that means man
i think it's a dope hat so you know i'm
gonna still rock it
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i hope you guys
enjoyed that podcast we will uh every
thursdays and sundays so far for this
month until
next year january i'm thinking about
flipping up the way that this uh podcast
looks instead of just having one angle
we might have three cameras kind of up
the production on it so you could get
one under the ball shot
right right into my penis
so i don't know if you guys will like it
but sometimes i just want to switch it
up and have a change um it's going to
cost a little more money but whatever if
it's once a week i might as well just up
the production on it but every every uh
thursdays and sundays until january 1st
of next year uh other than that guys uh
you can catch ed at ed2 on instagram and
also
secret society s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
dot com just dropped a new [ __ ] fire
ass line we're gonna talk about it on
another podcast um
or whenever it comes out it might be
before this one who knows
but uh new back to basics line um
probably one of my favorite lines that
we did so far especially because
everything is made domestic which means
the the quality of the cut and so
everything is [ __ ] amazing about it
and i know a lot of people out there
want to talk that you know their [ __ ] is
dope but you're still is still a blank
from a [ __ ] factory so don't you dare
talk to me about that [ __ ]
um but yeah every thursday sundays for
this month and then once a week starting
next year it's still going to be a dope
podcast we're going to keep it uh uh
going on sundays
uh every sunday is 12 p.m
and we'll see you all next time all
right joe peace